halfway through this parliamentary
session came an announcement by
Thailand's constitutional court that it
was suspending Peter Lim jaronrad as a
member of parliament Peter is the leader
of the move forward party and has 15
days to respond to allegations that he
had broken election laws by owning
shares in a media company the suspension
does not stop him from running for the
post of prime minister before he left he
delivered a short speech
I think Thailand is not the same anymore
ever since the May 14th election we have
come only halfway from the people's
Victory and there's another half to go
although move forward and its Alliance
Partners control the lower house their
choice for the Premiership has to be
supported by enough votes from the
mostly military-appointed Senate but
just as they did last week Senators
blocked his second bid to lead the
country on grounds a motion that's been
tabled and rejected cannot be
resubmitted I think it indicates the
absence of democracy rather than
anything else it's a clear indication
that leaders in Thailand Are Not Elected
by the people but they're merely
permitted to rise to power with
endorsement of the conservative South
Trip move forward supporters gathered at
a popular protest site expressing anger
at what they see as attempts by
pro-military elements to keep Peter out
of power
[Music]
I'm very mad we went through this four
years ago the country is going nowhere
and democracy is still being abused
what's the point in having elections
when you're going to throw democracy
down the toilet of course I'm upset but
I think many saw this coming I'm
disappointed that Peter is not going to
be prime minister but we have to remain
optimistic I don't think now is the time
to stop fighting we have to carry on
this protest is still relatively small
but depending on developments in the
days and weeks ahead similar
demonstrations could grow in size and
anger
officials from move forward and perthai
the second largest party in Parliament
and a coalition partner are expected to
meet to decide their next move
analysts have not ruled out per tie
forming a new alliance one that does not
include move forward in order to secure
votes from the Senate if that happens
large protests against the government
could break out across Thailand once
again
Florence Louis Al Jazeera Bangkok
Britain's inflation rates dropped more
than expected to 7.9